[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اتوقع الفوز يكون لمنتخب قطر الارجح فريق
متكامل يلعب على ارضه وبين جمهوره وفريق
متعوب عليه صراحه توقعت ال الاردن تقريبا
0 السباب لانه منتخب الاردن يمتلك ما شاء
الله لعيبه وعندهم الروح والاصرار
اتوقع اثنينهم صراحه يستحقون الفوز بس
الاقرب والمرشح الاكبر لان عنده جماعه
قطر اكيد الاردن الاردن قدمت مستوى كثير
كبير البطوله ها واعتقد انه في تفوق
تكتيكي وفني على قطر فان شاء الله راح
يكون حظ حليف الاردن وراح نرجع الاردن
بالكاس ان شاء الله والله اغلب الاحتمال
انه قطر تفوز لان المنتخب القطري له خبره
في هذا المجال في قبل سنتين فاز ويعني
الخبره اكثر من المنتخب الاردني ان شاء
الله نقول المنتخب القطري واذا فاز
المنتخب الاردني فالفوز يعني الكاس بروح
للعرب ان شاء الله الاردن لانها اول وصول
لها الى
النهائي حماسهم عالي جدا اتوقع المنتخب
القطري لانه حامل اللقب النسخه السابقه
وايضا لا نستهين بالمنتخب الاردني نتمنى
للجميع التوفيق ان شاء الله توقعي منتخب
قطر بحكم خبره في السابق وصل النهائي
الماضي وعنده لعيبه ما شاء الله اكرم عفيف
في المقدمه اللي هو حامل اثقل المنتخب
القطري اتوقع ان القطر ستفوز عندهم عناصر
اقوى ولان بين اغزهم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جماهيرهم